So I know that words that end with s or o need to have an es added. So if the
last letter is o, or the last letter is s, I return letters plus es. This
condition is pretty ugly. And it seems like I'm going to be talking about the
last letter index a lot. So I'm going to declare a variable. And now I can
replace all of these with just last. That looks a bit better. Let's see if our
program works for this case now. I'll need to return something in the else
clause. Since just adding an S seemed to be sort of a default leftover case,
I'll just return letters plus S here. I'll run my word tester. We want to look
at the cases that end with O or S. For example, kisses. It looks like right
now, our actual value for kisses matches what we expected. It looks like we
also got some for free. All of the leftover default cases where you just add an
s, are working pretty well right now. Massages look good, judges looks good,
laps, cats, clocks. But there are some that still aren't working, and dishes
should be disches, and not dish. So let's go back to our word. The case for y
being the last letter was a little bit more complicated, because it mattered
whether there was a consonant before it, or a vowel before it. So let's add a
case for when the last letter is y. We need to account for two possibilities.
If the second to last letter is a consonant, we take off the y and add yes. We
can use substring to cut off the last letter, which is the y. And then add back
ies. Otherwise, if the letter before the y is a vowel, we just add s. Now it
should be better. If I go back to my word tester, and run it one more time. It
should work for cherries, which it does. And it hasn't broken. Boys, or days,
which also ended in y. So that's a good sign. Still not working well for
dishes, or witches. It looks like if it ends in an h, then we need to return
the letters with an es instead of just s. Let's check that. It looks like
dishes is right, now. Witches is also looking better. Judges, laps, cats,
clocks, these all look good. But bathes isn't right now. Bathes just turned
into bathes. I think we need an exception for when there's a t before the h. So
let's go back and do that. If the last letter is H, then if is the 2nd to last,
so if the 2nd to last letter is an S or a C, then we add ES. Otherwise, just S.
And now, they should all match. So it looks like it works. But can we simplify
the code at all? The code I just wrote was pretty complicated. Now that you
have a working version, you could spend 5 minutes trying to simplify the code.
You can check whether your simplifications work by running the tester again.
And if you get a very simple or very short version, compare it with another
short version that I'm going to post in the forum. There should be a link
somewhere on the page.
[BLANK_AUDIO]